part c find the average value of f on
the interval negative 1 to 1. so the
average value of a function over an
interval is just going to be so let's
just write average the average value of
our function is just going to be the
integral over the interval negative 1 to
1 of f of x
d of x divided by our change in x so
divided by sorry this is from negative 1
to 1.
negative one to one f of x
d of x divided by our change in x and
our change in x is one
minus negative one so this is going to
be equal to one half
times the integral and here f of x is
piecewise defined so what we can do is
break up this integral into two
intervals we can say the integral of f
of x from
negative one to zero
of f of x dx
plus let me just write it this way so we
don't have to keep rewriting the one
half
let me write i'll do use brackets
plus the integral from
from 0 to 1 of f of x f of x dx and the
reason why i broke it up like this is
because this function is is has a
different definition or it takes it's a
different it's piecewise defined it's
different when we're when we're less
than or equal to zero and versus when we
are greater than zero so that's why i
like to break it up this way so then we
get this is equal to one-half times
and in brackets and big brackets like
this
this first part right over here we can
write as the integral from negative one
to zero what is f of x between negative
one and zero it's one minus two sine of
x
one minus two sine
of x d dx
and then plus this thing right over here
plus the integral from
0 to 1 and what is our function when
it's between 0 and 1 it's e to the
negative 4x
e to the negative 4x
dx and now we can do each of these
integrals separately
and so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to one-half
and once again i'll do a big open
bracket right over here my pen is
getting loose let me tie on the front a
little bit better there you go all right
back to work so one half open brackets
and now let's take the anti-derivative
of one minus two sine of x
anti-derivative of one with respect to x
is just x
negative 2 sine of x well the derivative
of cosine of x is negative sine of x so
this is just going to be
2 cosine of x and you can you can verify
that derivative cosine of x is negative
sine of x you have the 2 out front so
it's negative 2 sine of x
so we're going to evaluate that at 0
and at negative 1. and to that we're
going to add
so let's do this definite integral over
here the anti-derivative of e to the
negative 4 x the antiderivative is going
to be equal to
negative
negative e to the negative 4x
over 4. and the way you realize that is
if you had just an e if this was just an
e to the x then its anti-derivative
would just be e to the x if you have an
e to the negative 4x then you know that
whatever its anti-derivative is is going
to have a is going to be essentially an
e to the negative 4x but when you take
its derivative you're gonna have to take
the derivative of the negative 4x part
because of the chain rule and so you're
going to have to have a negative 4 that
comes out but we don't see a negative 4
over here we don't see a negative 4 here
so we're obviously going to have to
divide by a negative 4 so it cancels out
another way to think about it is
we could have rewritten we could have
rewritten this thing so this is equal to
e to the negative 4x dx this is exactly
what our problem is what we need to take
the definite integral and so that it
becomes completely clear so the
derivative of this thing is sitting
around here we could put a negative 4
over here but you can't just really
nearly throw a negative 4 there you
could put you would have to put a
negative 1 4 outside of it in order for
it to be in order negative 1 4 times
negative 4 you're not you're just
multiplying by 1 which doesn't change
the value and then here you'd clearly
see
here you'd clearly see that this is this
right over here is the derivative of
e to the negative 4x so you'd have e to
the negative 4x the antiderivative of
this is e to the negative 4x and then
you have this negative 1 4 over here so
either way
either way hopefully that makes sense we
go into more detail that earlier in the
calculus playlist
so then this is from we're going to
evaluate it at 1 and at 0
evaluated at 1 and at the zero
and then we want to close the brackets
and so what do we have here this is
equal to one half once again open the
brackets
if you evaluate all of this at zero you
get zero plus two cosine of zero cosine
of zero is one so you just get a two
when you evaluate it at the zero so you
get a two and then from that we want to
subtract whatever we get when we
evaluate it at negative one
we want to subtract negative one
plus two cosine of negative one plus two
cosine
to cosine of negative 1. so that's this
whole thing right over here evaluates to
this whole thing right over there
and then we have plus we want to
evaluate this at 1 so this gives us
negative
e to the negative four
it's four times one is just or negative
four x when x is one is negative four
over four and from that we need to
subtract this thing evaluated at zero we
need to subtract
this thing of value of zero so that's
going to be negative e to the zero over
four well that's just
e to the zero is one so that's just
negative one
over four and once again all of this is
going to be multiplied by one half
and now we just have to simplify it
so this is equal to well i'll just still
throw out the one half here this is
equal to one-half times
so i'll do this in a new color here let
me do it well i don't have too many new
colors okay so this is equal to two plus
one so this and this together is going
to be equal to three and then you have
this negative outside so that y that's
why it was a plus one and you have a
negative times a negative times a
positive two so minus two cosine
of negative one
and then you have plus
plus or maybe i should say minus
minus e to the negative four over four
and then you have plus 1 4
plus
1 4
and then we want to close our brackets
and then we can do one last step of
simplification here
3 we could add the 3 to the 1 4. 3 is
the same thing as twelve over four
twelve over four plus one fourth is
thirteen fourths so you have 13 fourths
minus two cosine
two cosine of negative one
minus e to the negative four over four
and then of course you have your one
half sitting out here
and it's not the most beautiful or
simple thing but this is this is our
answer this is the average value of f of
x over that interval